this is Startalk I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist recording
now from my office at the Hayden
Planetarium part of the American Museum
of Natural History right here in New
York City Chuck nice little what's up
nice comic on Twitter and this is a
cosmic queries edition yes we did
yeah okay we didn't specifically solicit
these right these trickle in over time
so this is a cosmic queries morbid
edition
oh my these are people asking just
questions about the ends of things yeah
death of things yes then I worry about
that people like what I worry sometimes
when we read somebody's questions yes
yeah we have definitely a very
death-obsessed audience we have a death
obsessed audience see what we can do
with them I don't even know how to bring
in an expert on that they're thinking
about an undertaker right right yeah but
okay so let's try it apparently these
are the questions that we get more than
anything else as it's categorize a
category you sort of soliciting a
category these trickle in as the biggest
unsolicited category all right all right
let's do it
so as usual we go from all over the
interwebs and we always start with a
patreon page Thank You patreon room
Thank You patreon that's right and this
is one of the ways we say thank you is
my reading your questions and giving
them priority so let's start with will
Jay who says what one or two skills
would you learn now to be useful and
productive in a post-apocalyptic world
this is of course if you survived the
meteor strike
so Apophis hits the world first of all
if Apophis is the world would we still
survive without human we human beings
survived oh yeah
so yeah yeah it would just disrupt
civilization would that be
post-apocalyptic with it would it
disrupt civilization mad max-style
all right regional yes okay yeah or a
boring his dog style okay I go way back
we wait okay right on Johnson won his
first movie I didn't know that yeah all
right he's the boy right and dog then
there's the dog so he's living on the
surface of the earth which is
apocalyptic civilization moved
underground all the I think all the men
became sterile of course and the men on
the surface were not so they grabbed him
brought him down to have him impregnate
land roots of women luckiest boy I ever
know they extracted the sperm from it
and then in great that that's the theme
if you need to know about a boy and his
dog that's that's Don Johnson an early
cinematic role but you can look at
movies and how they've portrayed these
lone survivors in apocalyptic earth and
they need it like three things they need
sort of a street smarts
you can go there's no Street survival
smarts survive Boy Scout level survival
smarts you probably Eagle Scout level
right and they all have some kind of
weapon true that can cause harm at a
distance so a bow and arrow or a gun you
don't want me up close and personal hand
hands this is my issue with the
lightsaber in Star Wars everyone's
looking at at it like it's some kind of
major amazing weapon when you have to
stand three feet from the person to use
it just think about that the whole point
of the advance of weaponry in the
history of warfare is so you don't have
to stand that close to anybody except
that you can deflect laser shot laser
bullets laser bullets yeah wait wait
wait so what I'm saying is if you have
enough time to notice it's coming and
then flick it out of the way right you
could just duck that is true okay you
just duck why are you ruining for me say
so I'm just not as impressed with the
lightsaber as everybody else is okay all
right it looks cool though okay so you'd
want to be able to protect yourself from
a distance right and you'd want access
to food and in a boring a dog the only
food left over on the ground was canned
food which would not was not spoiled by
the radiation or anything else that was
involved in it becoming apocalyptic
earth so I would also say
you need a can opener can't yes you do
in fact the dog could only serve dog was
smarter the dog is telepathic and a
genius
and he's not so the dog found the cans
basically Peabody and Sherman the dog
Sherman was his pet human do you
remember yes that's right that's right I
loved his wayback machine yes I loved
the time-travel that was in the cartoon
I'm that old to remember it that way
so so so you in that arrangement between
the dog and the boy the dog found the
food but the dog couldn't open the cans
but the boy could ah so they're
opposable thumbs when again mutual
survival depend right arriv okay so I
guess always carry candle burn about in
your back pocket day apart from that I
think some kind of hand-to-hand combat
would be useful right okay if some
stalks you up at night and then grabs
you right okay you can't then reach for
your action at a distance weapon okay so
you got to know some kind of martial art
all right not out like wrestling all
right
you got to have a weapon at a distance
okay you've got to have some kind of
survival sense right know how to find
the food how to prepare the food how to
make fire that sort of thing so I think
these are the basic these are the basics
in the apocalyptic earth and until
there's some organized rules my fear is
that we'll just resort to sort of
free-for-all oh god yes yeah are you
kidding me yeah we resort to a
free-for-all when the subway platform is
too crowded and you know who wins in the
end
whoo and I think about this every time
is the person who controls the hardware
store makes sense you walk into a
hardware store everything you need is
there yeah absolutely everything yeah
yeah including weaponry everything yeah
whatever you need it's right that's
right there for the apocalypse so there
you have it so Home Depot employees you
you will be our our Savior
when the post-apocalyptic world didn't
ask first well yeah all right cool
that's a cool by the way that's why it's
good for you to have a talent that other
people value that they can't just take
from you let your knowledge of how to do
things I thought you were gonna say
comedy well yeah well the first time
you're not funny that's the end of your
career no no that's the end of your head
what's real in your life right by the
way this has been studied in in the
walking dead
what's that so the danger is not the
zombie the zombies really okay the
danger is how people respond to each
other right so the interpersonal
relationships become most important most
important and who do you value and why
is someone overtaking the resources
relative to other people or some people
power-hungry that exploration became
most of what made the Walking Dead
interesting not all the innovative ways
they would kill the walking dead because
that's that gets redundant right after
like the fifth episodes only so many
ways you can kill a zombie was kill a
zombie right so so that exploration I
think was the most intriguing part of it
that's yeah I'm gonna give it to you I
have I didn't watch it that much but
what I did was that that is that's what
was most interesting it's like a soap
opera believe it is exactly like a soap
opera winter for example zombie so bunny
a quick other point I think about this
often if you're going to create an arc
of people mmm-hmm who will then
regenerate civilization on the other
side okay how are you gonna pick who's
on that arc right so if I were you I
would try to find some thing some talent
some trade that would be useful in the
apocalypse that will assure that you
might be picked to come on the orc right
right I'm trying to think like will
there be a nightclub there's a nightclub
on the arc I'm a good ship
pharming all right transportation or
communication right Michael right
exactly do we have liquor and do we have
night cuz then I can you know basically
I can generate generate a two-drink
minimum
and and entertainment all right that's
cool man all right next next question
right here we go
Salah muddy muddy wants to know this Wow
Wow I'm gonna share it with us okay
sorry I'm sorry
what if Wolverine with his regeneration
power was thrown into a black hole would
he still get spaghettified or would he
just continually regenerate interesting
ooh that's a weird question I like it
here's the thing the spaghettification
unless you're elastic man mm-hmm
splits you into pieces okay so if
Wolverine breaks into two halves and
those two halves continue to separate
there is no regenerating and injured
right because he's really an injured
he's still Wolverine he's just Wolverine
being like kind of streamed well if I
split you at the base of your spine
that's likely the first place you'll
break and then at the base of your neck
and then it's your knees and your hips
then he's Wolverine in eight parts what
does it mean to regenerate that I don't
even know cuz there's a gap in between
there exactly and the regenerative one
I've seen in the movies and in a comic
book
the regeneration requires that the gaps
are filled that are part of your body
and it fills in from where you already
had flesh that's true right right so I
think Wolverine that's it and even the
adamantium or whatever is the stuff is
that's adamantium and a black hole will
overcome any physical physical substance
correct okay
correct no matter what it is if it's
fictional and magical rank is still
gonna break right it's still an
dream of what single atoms correct now
do the atoms actually get spaghettify
yes Wow this is my point the nuclei get
even at Irvine Wow this is what this is
why I'm saying so okay so so what
happens is the tidal force of gravity
that's the stretching force right tides
that's where we get the word tides from
the tidal force of gravity becomes
greater than all other forces of nature
period period nice so the forces of
nature that hold the molecules together
that hold the atoms together right that
hold the nuclei together get ripped
apart by the tidal forces of gravity oh
wow okay I gravitate winds right so he's
spaghettified these all got to it no
matter what join join the club yeah
sorry rings all right Wolverine dad
that's a shame what's my boy's name the
actor you judge at you here in the club
Hugh Jack sorry he'll you in the club
yeah exactly spaghettified Club favorite
scene though of Wolverine gets shot in
the head and I don't know wit movie shot
in head falls to the floor everyone's
standing there a couple minutes later
the bullet pops back out and he gets up
anyway alright here we go this is phil
vader 23 from instagram right let's say
the world ends do you think that's the
end of the human race this could be at
any time it's a different way of saying
what we outlive this place do you think
how could how could you outlive the
planet that you live on I don't
understand okay so let's say for
instance there's no if earth is
destroyed no let's say I mean the earth
is gonna how long is the earth gonna
five billion years no we're here now yes
so we're 4.8 billion now right yeah four
and a half billion okay so now how far
do we have to go is my point
until when I'm saying like the Sun is
gonna burn out how far away yeah that's
what you're saying how far forward into
the future okay so if earth is ready to
get vaporized by the Sun right you need
some ability to plan it hop right
because the Sun will grow in size
the temperature of Earth's surface will
get hotter and hotter and hotter time to
move folks you pick up your luggage you
move to Mars
okay the next farther planet from the
Sun okay but the Sun will also start to
make Mars hot so then you want to move
farther out again yes then the Sun will
eventually die and no longer be a source
of energy to any of us then you want to
be able to star hop okay
find another solar system to move too
sure why not
so how long it would that all happened
at five billion years okay so if we got
another five billion years I am worried
about you I thank God I don't have to
put it on my calendar October 12th right
five billion and so let's just say we
solved all of our problems
cultural our social cultural problems
how long do you think we could make it
if we're not gonna kill our son out
gonna kill us which by the way I am sure
that's what's good ah
the average last I checked this this is
not my field of expertise okay just
relying what I've read and and but I do
work in a Natural History Museum
so I've colleagues who do this stuff I
last I remembered the average life
expectancy of a mammal species is
several million years so and we've been
around for several hundred thousand so
we should have waited a long way to go
if we don't kill us if we don't kill
ourselves and it might be that
intelligence as we've come to know it
and understand it is contraindicated of
the survival of the species so in other
words that there might be an inverse
relationship between intelligence and
survival we're out you might get so
smart that it's impossible for you to
survive because that's what causes you
to kill yourself correct because you
invent something that you think is cool
and it's the end of the world I think it
was was who's now who wrote
slaughterhouse-five old I think it was
Kurt Vonnegut who in one of his novels
he said I'm paraphrasing this is the
last sentence ever spoken by humans this
will be the last sentence ever spoken by
humans it'll be one scientist speaking
to the other saying let's try it the
other
oh god yeah that's funny okay Emma
listen right so you once you have the
power over nature and the forces of
nature are greater than you right or are
alternately greater than you then you
are wielding forces that can render
render your own extinction well you know
what that makes sense that there's a lot
of speaking of post-apocalyptic tropes
one post-apocalyptic trope is that
there's a huge self-destructive action
taken by humankind and then they decide
in the aftermath to live at one with
nature and to never go beyond that hmm
because that's hard though because
you're pumping water out of the water
table wait to drink
right you are redirecting a river so it
doesn't go through your home that's
interfering with nature almost
everything we do interferes with nature
farming is an interference of nature
right are the mono crop right so if you
want to live eat survive but you want to
live in harmony with nature you just
leave civilization and go in a cave and
we give you a knife and there you go and
you'll be dead at 35 all right that's
how you really want to do it that's how
you want to do that strongly about
nature do it I don't feel that strongly
about anything to live in a cave to be
honest so the next question all right
here we go the next one is JT parrot
he just says this I'm just gonna read it
as is does it end with a bang or a
whimper oh the universe will end in its
continued expansion to the future it
will end not in fire but in ice
and not with a bang damn that's cold so
what I did when we come back more cosmic
queries Edition the ends of things on
Startalk we're back to start on pricing
here nicely that's right that's right
all right what do you have ok let's move
on let's move or cosmic queries or
morbid addition or deletion yes good
right so what what this is a morbid
question and so DJ maths but just to be
clear we left off the previous segment
somebody asking simply well there's a
bang or a whimper and I gave like a
poetic poeta sized answer but let me
just give a little more put a little
more flesh on that bone ok so for the
for awhile in the 20th century once we
had Einstein's equation of gravity
mm-hmm the universe could be expanding
or contracting within that equation the
equation didn't distinguish one or the
other
ok observations showed we're expanding
right now we can ask will we expand
forever or will it one day slow down
stop and contract ok we make more
observations and we show no there's not
enough gravity to halt that expansion it
will expand forever once we learned it
would expand forever then we asked what
is the long-term profile of the universe
well the temperature will get further
further diluted as space expands oh
space-time expands right because all
that energy used to be concentrated here
and now it's half and then a third and a
tenth so eventually dissipates it
dissipates a good way to say the
intensity of energy dissipates the
temperature the universe drops right and
it'll never come back so and all the
stars will die and not get regenerated
because there's no everything will
separate from each other and so gas
clouds will make their final stars and
that's it so then the stars will
ultimately burn out one by one as the
sky goes dark
thus the universe ends but they'll nod
and fire but a nice and not with a bang
but with a whimper
that's kind of
sad for the universe I mean I don't want
to anthropomorphize I feel bad for the
universe now maybe that's a good way to
go yeah you know I wouldn't mind going
like that there you go
you know which brings us to our next
question what a great segue you just
made DJ Mass 2006 on Instagram says Neil
how do you want to die oh this is public
knowledge oh really oh yeah okay yeah I
bet if you type
how does Neil Tyson wanted to hold on no
I'm gonna do it rested I gotta test it
out on handi hold on alright here we go
alright I'm gonna talk to my phone how
does Neil deGrasse Tyson want to die
okay and okay clearly you have done this
because one two three four five six
seven eight YouTube videos came up about
you dying somehow here's you in the
afterlife here's you on I don't fear
death here is you on near death in
near-death experience why you talk about
death it's not that I come out of the
box doing this is that people come to me
asking about it okay so how do I choose
to die I would delight and if I were
near my deathbed okay near temporarily
near my deathbed I would say don't lay
me down to die launch me into that black
hole so I can be spaghettified oh wow
and I will report back until I no longer
can and I'll be the first human day
spaghettified identified nice I will
totally go that I might get some sauce
for the meal we need some slots for this
man sauce okay so your ID sauce that's
kind of cool actually all right if
that's how you're gonna go but do you
think that would hurt seriously yeah I'm
gonna be it'll be yeah and you're
pointed do you think it'll hurt being
stretched and ripped apart by tidal
force well my point is does it would it
happened so quickly that it wouldn't
make a difference it's or would it
happen to the point where you would be
thoroughly aware of every single part I
mean until you couldn't you feel like
you're stretching it say that's good
nobody doesn't like a good stretch
absolutely then it is unrelenting and
say okay I'm done now no so that's I
know how we play that okay and then you
stretch and then you snap into two
pieces now the thing is all your vital
organs are in the upper half of your
body so you'll stay you'll likely stay
awake even after you lose your lower
half Wow
and and then you know if you suffer at
the neck they did experiments at the
French Revolution let's use you can
still see yeah right yeah and so they
get blinked you know to for a few
seconds yeah so I die it's how I would
do it okay
I want my death to have some value to
science all right and that's how you do
that that is where we differ I want to
die in my sleep feeling nothing do you
know all right well that's cool man
there you go spaghettification all right
but this concept of feeling nothing by
dying in your sleep I don't know if it
was just my immaturity or my my
literalism of I cuz I I I was a geeky
kid okay and everything was literal to
me I could not think figuratively about
anything and I would like rethink things
like six and one half a dozen of the
other
yeah I thought is it six of one half a
dozen of the other
well that would be three and twelve
because why would anyone say six one
half a dozen of the other
why would anyone say that if if those
are the same if there isn't it right
right so what's the point so maybe they
meant something else so I thought 6 is
1/2 well that's three and a dozen of the
other
so maybe they say there's three of these
and twelve so I had a very literal mind
and one of them was trying to understand
people learning when people died by
taking sleeping pills mm-hmm what I'm
thinking
how could you die by playing sick taking
sleeping pills don't just go to sleep
like what what like I can imagine dying
by taking poison right yes I get that
okay you can die by gunshot wound by
nice by falling off a cliff but just by
going to sleep and then I had to learn
that
you can take too many pills right and
then your body just stops working but on
route to you having digested these pills
you simply fall asleep so I defected
deduce this from first principle that's
all I'm saying
well you just described my favorite way
to die yeah but without the pill part I
don't want that part you just want to go
I just wanna go to sleep and not wake
God okay many people in my family have
died that way really yeah yeah well
here's the thing I was just thinking
about this this morning okay you read
about someone's death and they said they
died peacefully in their sleep right
does that mean if they don't say that
that they were screaming in total agony
so that's why why even mention that but
so I guess it brings comfort to people
right but but peacefully this that's a
comfort part right but if you died in
pain and agony you're not gonna tell
that to someone so now I'm thinking if
they don't say they died peacefully that
that's actually how it happened yeah um
I would say that's almost they do nice
why not go quietly yeah okay yeah yeah
now I'm wondering if you woke somebody
up right before they died would they
then not die peacefully in their sleep
but in agony because you woke them up
okay this is an experiment I don't
really want to do I do just like yo wake
up okay all right here we go Mike
Ireland wants to know this I know that
you covered artificial intelligence what
do you think the percentage is that
computers have already garnered human
consciousness and are they laying them
whoo come on now is it an eerie thought
and I just love your opinion on the
matter
are they lady laying them wait until the
right time to do what to get rid of us
all so you're saying
computers are pretending to not be full
up AI yet they've already achieved it
okay now this is a pod by the way at
first I was laughing at this guy and now
that I just heard you say it I'm scared
okay because that could actually be the
case
okay if you are an AI that is is truly
an AI yeah right they could do that and
you knew they could make you know that
if you expose the fact that you were an
AI okay true intelligence you there
right that you would go ahead and plug
me then I go well I can't let you know
that and then I chill until there's the
right time where I can get rid of you or
not be unplugged right before you before
you unplug me or not be unplugged one or
the other I would either wait until I
can't be unplugged or I get rid of you
and so you can't unplug me yeah okay so
that was kind of the plot in the remake
of War of the Worlds really yes okay
they they did not follow the script from
the original HG Wells story right this
is the one 2004 Tom Cruise Tom Cruise
right okay in that version the aliens
lay dormant and buried underground
that's right
damnit right I forgot about that right
and then they found the right moment and
then they all rose up right
okay now that idea which perhaps they
thought was clever I it it undermines
the entire plot of the movie okay which
is which is alien invasion from another
foot from another planet right who are
overcome not by our weapons but by germs
that they do not have immunity to
because they did not evolve on this
planet right so that premise is they had
to be here a long time ago to put that
stuff in the ground yes and now they're
in the ground now they're in the ground
can be they can develop an immunity our
germs that entire premise unraveled in
the presence of this new idea they're
gonna pre bury the aliens gotcha yeah so
that'd piss me off
I'm just saying well I'm with you on
that that was okay who's a crap movie so
I mean you know don't get me wrong
love Tom Cruise okay love them you know
that movie had a narrator wait no yes it
did no we have to do how that's your
dude I've seen it twice I don't remember
a narrowing okay just take a guess and
there's a 50% chance you'll get the
right narrator mmm-hmm Tim Robbins Oh
[Music]
morgan freeman what yes that's right it
did he's oh my god and he comes on at
the end the end and I got the end quote
right that's right I read with me all
right here we go
carry this narration with me all right
all right the end of the 2005 were the
world from the moment the invaders
arrived breathe our air ate and drank
they were doomed
they were undone destroyed after all of
man's weapons and devices had failed by
the tiniest creatures that God in His
wisdom put upon this earth by the toll
of a billion deaths man had earned his
immunity his right to survive among this
planet's infinite organisms and that
right is ours against all challenges for
neither do men live nor die vain nice
translation whose house my anyway that
wouldn't happen if they years right and
by the way I just find it so ironic that
one of the most recognizable voices on
on the planet is doing a reading of the
most recognizable how meta is that Neil
deGrasse Tyson does Morgan Freeman you
know that's what that's cool but did you
like mine I did I like them by the way
that's a great great little quote when I
read when I heard it I said it's
beautiful right now the novel was a 19th
century Victorian era novel and I said
that's beautiful language I bet it was
verbatim from the story mm-hmm okay cuz
nobody today writes like that I know for
neither do men lived nor die
no eh that's not coming out anybody in
Hollywood today no so I said let me find
the original but I had another little
issue I said this makes very strong
mention of God mm-hmm and I said well HG
Wells was highly scientifically literate
did he make mention of God I went back
and found the passage no he does not
make mention of God here is HG Wells's
original passage oh snap cover
that part of what was used for the movie
okay you ready go ahead for so it had
come about as indeed I and many men
might have foreseen had not terror and
disaster blinded our minds these germs
of disease have taken their toll of
humanity since the beginning of things
taken toll of our pre-human ancestors
since life began here but by virtue of
this natural selection of our kind we
have developed resisting power to no
germs do we succumb without a struggle
and directly these invaders arrived
directly they drank and fed our
microscopic allies began to work their
overthrow already when I watched them
they were irrevocably doomed dying and
rotting even as they went to and fro it
was inevitable by the toll of a billion
deaths man has bought his birthright of
this earth and it is his against all
comers it would still be his were the
Martians ten times as mighty as they are
for neither do men live nor die in vain
whoa hash tag Darwin rocks
he's got pre-human ancestor he's got
natural selection of things no mention
of God these are two different things
I think Hollywood was afraid to get
realized oh yeah there you go we gotta
call this segment quit we'll be back
with the third segment of cosmic queries
the Deaf edition on Startalk Chuck last
segment start talking that's right let's
McQueary
yes the Deaf edition - alright alright
alright let's jump right back into it
give it to me this is um Jay Decatur I'm
gonna say Decatur I'm going with ya yes
it's probably J Decatur it might be but
you know it's Jaden J I'm with you on
this alright good for you that day why
don't you change your last name to Jones
we won't have a problem he says this
what does it merging a black holes mean
for the future of the universe could the
universe eventually be the victim of a
collective hyper massive black hole
could we be left with a singularity or
black hole containing all the
information of this universe waiting for
the next big bang trigger hmm hmm
everything in the world just ends up
into one giant Lac hole that creates a
singularity that then because the
universe okay so black holes are not
quite what you think they are right
they're not giant sucking machine no not
okay so if the Sun became a black hole
earth would still go right around good
shrink down the Sun and make it a bottle
earth would still go around in orbit
like it was it would be dark and cold
right but orbitally it wouldn't make no
difference to us so now so just because
it's a black hole doesn't mean it's
reaching out right in places it didn't
previously reach out to eat you so are
you saying that anything in orbit around
a supermassive star that collapses under
its own self and becomes a black hole
right if if if it's already in that
orbit correct then it will not cross the
event horizon create it by that black
hole and let's continue to be in that
same orbit correct unless the black hole
eats for by some other means then the
black hole gets bigger ah if you fed the
black hole top and bottom okay
now the black hole will grow its gravity
will increase and it could increase to
such a point where your speed and orbit
is insufficient to maintain your orbit
that's and then you orbit decays and you
fall in that could happen okay yeah okay
but but it's like I said isn't the
object had to have been headed towards
the black hole to get eaten again which
right right so it's not some giant
sucking machine first of all second
modern evidence shows there was not
every galaxy certainly most galaxies red
blooded galaxies have supermassive black
holes in them when galaxies collide it
is highly likely that these black holes
will find each other all right because
that's how the dynamics of colliding
systems works and
and they will consume each other passing
through each other's event horizon
that's yeah okay so then you have a
black hole twice as big now alright fine
but then it's just still stuck in the
middle of this these two galaxies that
have merged right tonight it's not
reaching out to some other galaxies all
right so now now we have an accelerating
expanding universe so there's a galaxy
over there and I'm a galaxy over here
and expanding universe will forever take
that black hole away from my black hole
right so so you're all moving away from
it there's no reason to think that all
the matter in the universe is gonna land
up as one black hole that's yeah not
only that the universe is just going to
expand forever and forever is a long
time it is it's not long enough for the
Bible though the Bible it's forever and
ever you ever notice that is yeah ever
and ever and ever
right cuz forever however big that
infinity is I want more info plus one
plus one Oh you the gnawing kid 200
billion one hundred billion one that's
how to get an ass-whuppin industry man
alright so now in the very distant
future of the universe the black holes
that did eat whatever it was they were
gonna eat right will ultimately
evaporate and what's called Hawking
radiation okay so the black hole becomes
undone and all that matter that was in
the black hole is now back scattered
into the scattered back into the
universe so now if you do the math and
ask how much mass is there within the
radius of the known universe and see how
that compares to a black hole's mass and
size it turns out the entire universe
can be analogized to being a black hole
unto itself with a horizon beyond which
you cannot see Wow
so it is not completely crazy to think
of the universe and all that's going on
within it as containing a black hole
that has all the external properties
that any black hole we're looking at
would have within us within our universe
okay so then you ask if we are a black
hole are we a black hole in some larger
universe as I was about to say so who's
to say that there's not more universes
with the same black hole that we would
be correct this is what this is what led
to the idea that maybe black holes are
portals to entire other space-time
continuum haha so in men in black the
galaxy on the belt of Orion right he
remember this yes okay it's a little
weird to have said it that way if it
were a black hole on the belt of Orion
then that would legitimately be an
entire other universe right but they
just said galaxies and you can get a
nice picture of a galaxy and you go into
that galaxy then it's another galaxy but
that's not as scientifically realistic
as there being a black down to on the
belt and then you go into the black hole
there's a whole universe got you yeah
okay all right well well the answer to
your question is no not pronounce his
name again
yeah Jade Gator or as I'll call you Jay
Jones
all right cool cool cool and I said his
name is probably Jada Gator you said
that yes bet I bet you a dollar Jay we
read your question hit us up on Twitter
let us know how bad I mangled your your
name all right okay okay this is a Tory
Himelstein or Himmelstein I'm gonna go
with Himelstein so Tory says this hey
physics undergrad here in aus physics in
the house is there any chance that after
I die my atoms would spontaneously
combine to form an alien billions of
years in the future the answer is yes
Tory don't listen to charge the
interesting thing about the universe
mm-hmm that's not entirely obvious at
first reckoning is that every electron
we've ever found is identical to every
other electron every atom of any species
of
I'm a species loosely there obviously
any oxygen atom here is identical to any
oxygen atom anywhere else in the
universe right so we are composed of
elements drawn from the periodic table
of elements
correct and the naturally occurring
elements is 94 depending how you count
it the low-90s
naturally-occurring elements that is the
recipe that makes everything there is in
the universe mm-hmm everything natural
in the universe so if you made a these
atoms I put you in the earth and you
decompose these atoms are available to
make something else right and to
decompose is different from then to sit
disintegrates right you know the
different no to disintegrate as you
break apart right to decomposes some
other animals eating you know is that
really yes if I put even if it's the
ground or microbes or anything it's
still something else consuming correct
that's right if I buried you on the moon
you will not decompose because there's
no microorganisms not your body that's
right you'll just stay there and you'll
you'll be hydrate some atoms some
molecules will change but not because
they were were decomposed now I know how
I want to die I want to die well how I
want what I want to be after I die and
when somebody to put me in a
Barcalounger type chair and put a drink
in my hand and just sit me on the moon
oh yes
so with sunglasses right right
you'll be there dehydrated but it'll
still be there right okay Wow hmm so
basically this there's a movie that
ended that way what yes
no who's that who's the main star men in
black not will submit the other guy uh
Tammy Lee Jones
Tommy Lee Jones in this movie ends dead
on the moon leaning up against a rock
looking out into space that's cool yeah
Tommy Lee Jones I don't know what movie
that is I think it was space cowboys
okay I think not bad I think we can
check on this not
way to deny somebody looked that up yeah
but what you're saying though is from
from from Tory's question so we're just
all information so there's more
ingredients we're ingredient ingredient
ingredients basically yes and so that's
why I want to be buried
rather than cremated right because I
want the energy of my molecules in my
body to be available to other organisms
if you if you if you are cremated your
energy gets dispersed into space right
that's fine you might enjoy that like
that but the rest of what is you is or
all the atoms are broken apart and other
creatures can't can't utilize them you
don't you don't have nutritional value
right right but you'll still exist as
atoms right so aliens that might evolve
on this planet or some other planet if
your atoms were taken there yeah you
could be composed it part of another
atom yeah there you go we're kids are
ingredients that's it that's it nothing
more than flour milk eggs boil milk
waffles we're waffles good one last
question
one last question here we go let's young
rats won't you Rex young wants to know
this how long could a person endure
prolong isolation
such as during solo interplanetary
travel or colonization before space
madness
okay becomes an issue okay we don't have
time for this but I want to do it anyway
figure it out okay okay go ahead Chuck
all right I'm old enough to remember the
twilight zone in first run not the
earliest with it later slightly later
years okay like in the 60s it went into
the mid-60s it's still on so okay all
right so there were so many episodes
about astronauts going crazy for lack of
human interaction right okay I said wow
this is gonna be a big Pro the biggest
problem we're gonna face okay is people
going crazy in isolation in space then I
met people who don't like talking to
other people who don't like anybody who
would be just fine months
years at a time never having a human
contact with anybody else I met these
people and sometimes I feel that way to
perfect astronauts I'd say I say give me
a you know a good video account some
books some give me Apple dappled you
know Apple music mm-hmm and I'm good I
don't have to talk to anybody so this
idea that you need human contact for
your survival people I have met
undermine that claim that I have seen
persistently made in in storytelling but
apart from that okay
nASA has never sent anybody up alone
since mercury okay right a B NASA's
always yapping at you on the radio
that's true yeah they do all the time
mm-hmm all the time you're talking to
you that's true
how you feel today did you turn the knob
to the left three times right did you do
the hokey-pokey spacewalk did he do the
thing did you did you have a bowel
movement right no and so it ain't like
they're not there right so anyhow I
think there's enough range of people's
interpersonal temperament that I I don't
see that it's gonna be a problem
having somebody alone now you want to
know who is the most isolated person
that ever was
no who was it it was the command module
pilots in the in the nine Apollo
missions to the moon where well sorry in
the missions where two of them went down
to the surface right so that's seven of
the missions where including Apollo 10
where they went down just above the
surface that's okay
come back right and they never actually
landed because they're incrementally
testing god those guys got ripped off oh
god I know what would you yeah I'm
thinking you see Houston I can't hear
like I'd be like Chuck Sullenberger you
know I'm gonna have to set her down I'm
sorry Zoe from
put her down I gotta put her down yeah
yeah I got a problem we ran into a flock
of geese sir but I have to set her down
on the moon Apollo there are no geese on
the moon anyhow so the command module
pilot while on the far side of the moon
was the farthest human there ever was
from any other human okay okay right so
they were the width of the moon away
from any human plus some orbital
distance into solo people that's it
that's the most solo person ever that
there ever was all right
nice so we don't any more time okay yeah
thanks for these question these were
great yeah these were good he's always
the morbid addition I think we have more
question do this my god just like 40
pages of these questions people are
really the inaugural cosmic queries more
morbid edition you heard it here you
heard it now Chuck thanks as all how
pleasure Neil deGrasse Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist bidding
[Music]